Most of the time, when we start working with him directly, advise him about some stuff, he's good for a couple of days, then he backs to back to the way that he could handle stuff, so I would say it takes more energy from us to.
help him than the way that he helped us. So yeah, I would say nothing changing in his side in terms of Jasp and the rest of the technician that we have with ITBD by Design.
Yep.
In progress, improvement, we can see some improvement, but it's too slow. Again, if I want to compare it with the other technician that we have in the team, they need more effort to reach them, but at least we...
don't have kind of like a specific issue with client and their type of communication with them. I think Jasper is good in the communication style. I'm not sure about Paxton. Torin can give us insight about Paxton.
Okay.
About Jimmy, I heard some good things about Jimmy to how to communicate with the client. Yeah, these are all input that I have. But you know, I'm in the pressure of a replacement for Ranch, and I think the reason why we have Karine here in our site is because of that.
S.
Yep.
Great.
Yes.
The.
Yeah, so far, Paxton's been very comparable to Jimmy, from what I've seen of the interactions between him, the team, Arkadi, myself. Unfortunately, today he had a bit of an incident, but it was not of his own doing. He was assigned a group A ticket by accident, ended up on a call with one of our VIPs. But we re-rescued him fairly quickly from that and got him transferred over to another technician to take over.
But he handled it well, apologized, and got it over to Arkadi and I right away, and so we were able to take care of that for him. So that was a good sign. Yeah, it was an unintentional error on our triage's part, but the way he went, the way that Paxton reached out to us, I thought was really good. Just admitted that he's...
S.
stuck, we were able to jump in, kind of have a quick look, and I pulled one of the SMEs for that client to go in and kind of make sure everything was moved over. But yeah, overall, I find, sorry, Paxton and Jimmy very similar. I think their skill sets a little bit higher than maybe Jasp's and Vanch's, but...
Yeah.
Kasper is.
Taking to the team fairly well as well, so that's my.
One of the common things that I heard from the team from our client, because you know I do have a day-to-day meeting with our account managers and they typically speak with client. I do have regular cadence with our client. They don't mention any name, but
Right.
It.
They say, recently we have some issues with your Helpdesk technician. They don't know how to communicate with us. They are robot. They can, they don't use any kind of like human being stuff with us. And one of them translated to being rude. I don't want to mention.
what happened between us and them, but at the end, I'm not sure how we can align it. We try our best to train them, but some of those things are not trainable, or if it is, it's outside of our control. I just wanted to let you know that it happened.
There had, based on my last conversation with Tammy and account managers, they mentioned something and I think Arkadi had the same meeting with Tammy. She mentioned something same to her.
Tell me, tell me, Lynn, tell me, Lynn.
No, tell me Namit.
No, time in name and it's yeah, yeah, she's our vice president.
Vice President.
Ohh, OK.
And she had a meeting with, she had a couple of meetings with our client. And it's not only for one client. So overall feedback about the recent hire that we had. I'm not sure, Arkadi, if you want to add some more insight about those meetings that you had.
It seems to depend on the specific technician from ITBD, where some are communicating to our standards with clients. They're friendly, they use language that the clients are familiar with, and the rest seem to rely a lot on AI tools.
which are giving them language that isn't very familiar for our clients, or they use terminology that our clients call like, huh, what does this mean? For religious poor grammar in general, then that's in the written communication. In terms of verbal communication, they...
are not sufficiently polite with clients. They don't put themselves in the client's shoes and thinking, okay, if I say this to the client, how will this be interpreted from them? Like not taking responsibility, for example, if somebody calls in about the ticket, they should never ever tell a client, this is not my ticket.
I cannot help you, right? They should be either taking over the ticket or examining the ticket and trying to help instead, and then or offering to transfer to that person, to that other person who is a ticket owner. The I cannot help you should never be something that they sell to any client. And.
then there is the whole situation with I don't know who you are and where you're coming from. So even if you don't actually know who this person is and you're not familiar with their company, you should at least pretend that you are, right? Because we have clients who go back over a decade.
and who have an expectation of the technician being familiar with at least their company, in some cases even with them personally. We build a relationship with our VIP users. So when they call in and they ask for a specific technician, or they get a specific technician, they're like, oh, okay, we know this person, we know they can help us.
I.
We are confident that we're going to get the help that we need here, right? It's about the ability to build a rapport with the user and the client in general. I understand it's a tough skill to develop, but in some cases, they don't seem to be even trying to do that.
Yep.
They're so focused on fixing the technical issue, they forget the rest of the experience that the user should have, on the client should have, right? But...
For us, it's always a two-part job. It's the people handling and it's a technical issue resolution. And both are equally important, right? So, and if I can just, like, in my experience so far, Jimmy is fantastic in both the technical issue.
Yeah, I completely agree with you.
and in terms of handling client communications and how he handles himself on the phones and written communication. I seem to have the same impression from Paxton so far. And Jasp started out as an issue, but he has gotten a lot better in that sense, a lot better. The only one who still has trouble with communication is Vanch.
at this point.
Yep, so we are replacing him already and we are in the process of identifying his replacement. So yeah, it's good that we identified the person who is not up to the mark as per the standards of the customer service and MSP Corp standards. So we are in the process of replacing him. So yeah.
Yeah.
And.
Right.
Key.
Regarding the technical trainings as well, there was another pending item. So, Reza, we connected last week where we were waiting on the slots so that we can have a genius trained on the topics shared by Arkadi. So, looking forward to get the slots from you when we can
which can be utilized for the trainings.
Should it be in working hour or we can handle it after our weekends?
So, initially, I proposed that half hour from a genius break can be utilized in half half an hour from their shift timings, but that was that was not something that Arkadi was aligned with, so I guess we have to do it out of their break timings, and
Yeah.
Yes, Arkadi.
Reza, my preference would be for this to happen somewhat in the middle of the day, so that they can, so that all four of them can be on the same session together, and because their shifts only overlap in the middle of the day, that's when it should happen, right? And it should be outside of the lunch hours, because those...
Mhm.
do not happen at the same times, like not even close. And also I need them to take lunch so they can be fresh for the rest of the day after their lunch as well. But ideally, so that there is no duplication or triplication of effort, it should take in the same time slot in the middle of the day for them.
Yeah.
Mhm.
And how many days it take? How many days it take?
Which would be, yeah.
So...
For the whole process of training.
Okay, cream.
Okay.
Well, not just the training piece, but hands on too.
Yeah.
Yeah, and it's one hour every one hour a day, right?
One out a day, yes.
Okay, if you want to have 4 technicians, one hour a day for three months means I lose half technician for three months, right?
I lose half of half a technician resource for three months.
I'm not sure we can handle it.
It's A lot; it's a half a technician for three months.
Kip.
What if we were to focus on the most important topics?
Yeah, I would say so, 'cause, 'cause you know, the best way is, 'cause you know, if you, if you wanna, if you wanna handle training part, I'm not sure Karine knows about that. Let me, like, let me explain what the plan is. Yeah, the plan is, Karine.
Shukla.
Yeah, yes, please.
We found that they have some technical issues in terms of the skill set that we need. We had a couple of meetings with Ashish Lee and...
Mm.
Amit.
Amit, which is the point that we can prepare a list of the technical skill set, give them to IT by design. They're going to prepare the trainer for the plan for training the people. It's A win-win plan for us, because you know, in one side,
After the technical training, they're going to handle our task better. And in other side, it would be a good point for IT by design to show us that they train technical part of staff at their side. And the...
The process-wise, they cannot train people in terms of process, and we do it in our site, but based on the plan, I think it's a lot for us to lose.
like half a technician for three months. I'm not sure if we can somehow adjust it, like say one of the adjustment would be based on what Arkadi says. We can go through and prioritize the training, like say these items is important for us and prioritize those.
Mmh.
And also, if the IQ by Design have any policy with the technicians to somehow start training outside of our business hour, like say, for during the weekend, or a compact camp for them every week, like they in.
on Saturdays, on Sundays, or maybe if we have any Canadian stash holiday, we can say, OK, give them a vacation, they can, they can be at a training part on those days, and...
Then somehow I adjust it.
It's it would be better planned than losing half of our half a technician in a day.
The.
Yeah, go ahead, go ahead.
There is a July 1st coming up, Canada Day, that's a whole day that can be dedicated to, or at least most of the day can be dedicated to the training that covers what?
Yeah.
We have what, 8 hours in a date for training. That's like 8 days worth of training sessions, right? Yeah.
HR words.
Yeah, and also we can assign Saturday as well to them. We can exclude them from the shift for Saturdays. Arkadi, if, I'm not sure, you put, you scheduled them for the shift for the weekend shift. Torin, you do that, right?
Do you mean on call?
Pre.
On call, yeah, yeah.
Right, you on call.
Well, I mean, I don't do the scheduling. The schedule is kind of in place. I modify things and announce the stuff, but would it make sense to do that while during on call then?
Ahh.
Okay, no, no, no, just I wanna I wanna I wanna exclude them from any shift that we have. If we can like assign one day of the weekend for the training in your side, Ashish, and then once a once a week.
Thank you.
during the working hour, it does make sense for us to handle it. Otherwise, from day-to-day stuff, I think it's not possible.
All right, so thank you so much for the inputs, Reza Arkadi. So the trainer who is there to provide them trainings on the topics that you have mentioned, he is available between 8 to 5 Eastern. So the training ideally has to happen within
his availability. That's one. Second, the sessions will be recorded. So what I was planning to propose is who you think is a junior who is more absorbent to the technologies that you
think is can go for the trainings first. Like say 2 engineers can go for the training complete and rest of the guys can watch the recordings and have their questions answered. This is the only thing that I can think of so that you have 50% of the engineers there to manage the queue and the tickets and rest of the team.
I see.
them would go for the training.
Mhm.
I'd say Jimmy and Paxton will probably be the most likely to absorb that information based on their technical skill right now.
Hmm.
So, this is something that that's your call, and you let us know.
And we can...
No, these, those are those are good proposals, Ash, and we can, you know, we can take it back and look at, you know, the feedback and the options beyond that. But I think that's a good starting point as far as being able to kind of speak to your concern, Reza, because we hear it. We just want to make sure we're
Kip.
Not delaying the opportunity to discuss alternatives, so...
Mm.
Kip.
Yeah.
Yeah, so we can adjust it in this way, if you agree, guys. First, prioritize the skills that we need based on based on our most day-to-day tickets that we have.
Yep.
I'm not sure if we can minimize it to one month plan first. Like say, have 10 topics for one month, 2 topics for one month, whatever we need based on Arkadi and Torian decision. Then 2 technicians start working on that business observation.
which is good.
And what if we, what if we, because you know I can recall, Karine, you can confirm it, other views has half an hour launch time, right?
And only be only our view has one hour lunch time.
Can we somehow minimize their lunch time to half an hour? And then we can assign another half as a working hour in our site and half for the lunch time.
Karine, can you do do you know what the what the launch time is for other views or?
I don't know. Lee, do you have these details?
Forgive which details their lunch hours?
Yep.
Yeah.
Yes.
No, it is it is one hour for every BU. Yeah, I'm sorry, I thought you were reporting to the internal to MSP Corp. OK, for for ITBD, yes, it's one hour for rest of the pods, yes.
Oh, whatever.
Yeah.
Okay, okay, so we cannot minimize it to half an hour. Let's have it one hour. Yeah, I agree with the plan. But the plan should be for one month, focus on the priority, then try and see what happens during that one month. If we need more, definitely we can expand it.
This.
Okay, and we will first go with Jimmy and Paxton.
I agree.
And Kam.
Yes, that would be the idea.
Okay.
Right, yes, Arkadi, you were saying something I dropped it.
Well, after the one month, there will be the opportunity to catch up with more topics on July 1st for the for Canada Day, which...
All of us will be off, except for the on call person.
Yes.
Sure, that will be done. And so what should be the time that we can keep for this training? Because Jimmy starts at 11 Eastern, Paxton starts at 9 Eastern. So do you think somewhere around...
3 Eastern would be fine because that is the almost end of the shift where the workload is less and you have things planned like which customer needs to be reached out at what time. And calendar would be sorted. This is what I wanted to say.
Three to four would work from my perspective.
3 to 4 Eastern.
Yeah.
84.
Mhm.
I do have a call right on based on the time.
Thank you.
Share my screen.
Here is my call volume. You say three to four, right? Four is one of the highest call volume that we have in afternoon, so...
The.
3 is 26, 33, 37. Yeah, I think 3 to 4 is the best.
Yes.
Kour.
Five to six.
Oh, they're not available 5 to 6, right?
Oh, Paxton, Paxton should be ready. He's in deal 6, right? So he, it will be the last hour of his shift for Paxton.
And how about Jamie?
Jimmy is working 11 to 8, so he would be available too.
Okay, my recommendation is 7. It's 5 to 6, I would say.
For the training.
Yeah.
Is it doable on your side, Ashish?
So, Reza.
Yep, the trainer would not be available at both 5.
All right, right.
Ohh, I see, I, I see. OK, your trainer available 8 to 8 to 5. Gosh, OK, if it is 8 to 5, the only time that we have is 3 to 4.
8 to 5, yes.
Maybe we can...
Three to four, 12 to one.
Yeah.
Idea 3 to 4 is better because sometimes things really explode around lunch.
I.
Priya.
Oh yeah, go ahead for three to four.
Right.
Let me just take a note of it.
Okay, so I will discuss this with the trainer and share the complete plan with you so that, and then we can decide on the date when we want to start with this training. Most likely, it's going to be 8th of June because, you know, start of the week should be the one that
we should aim for. By this way, we'll be able to gauge completion of the weeks and see the progress and the topics covered.
Mhm.
I see. Okay, and can you book him for July 1st as well?
Yeah, sure. So this is something we can discuss, you know, as the time would progress. And I will also reach out to you regarding this holiday ahead of time to ensure the coverage and availability of the engineers. And so we can discuss all these things during this time. So no worries from that standpoint.
Yep.
Karine.
Kip.
Any other feedback or suggestions?
Go ahead, Karine.
Yes, correct.
I will need to go, but I want to make sure that you understand that the Reza, it's a replacement vanch. I'm sorry for the pronunciation. It's P1. I sent an email this morning and I'm pretty sure that everybody's working on it, but want to make sure that if we're able to have the resume as soon as possible.
Prince.
Get back to me if it's possible for an update for the boat role we have, but especially for Reza, because now it's critical.
Yeah, yeah, you're in a bad situation.
heard, heard, curry, and absolutely.
Sure, sure, yep, it's a payment.
OK, thank you.
Thank you, Karine.
Thank you.
Kip.
See you. Bye-bye.
You're welcome.
Bye.
Okay, Lee, do you want to add something?
No, just to appreciate your guys' collaboration on figuring out the timing of that. Obviously, you know, like you said, this is intended to be a win-win-win, right? Helpful for you, helpful for us, helpful for the engineers. So, yeah, thank you for kind of digging in the weeds and sorting through that with us.
Yep.
Just.
Thank you, I appreciate you guys.
Alright, well, in that case, I will call it a meeting. We'll meet on 9th of June. Until then, please take care of yourself and have a good one.
Have a good day. Bye.
Kip, you too.
Yeah. Thanks, everybody.
Bye.
Yeah.
Bye, bye.